wasser hat sich in den vergangenen
jahren zu einem echten lifestyle produkt
entwickelt angeboten werden nicht nur
wasserflaschen
mit echten swarovski kristallen sondern
beispielsweise auch sündhaft teures
wasser von den fidschi-inseln edelstein
wasser oder wasser mit einer art
gedächtnis das soll vitalität schönheit
und gesundheit bringen was steckt
dahinter
und ist es überhaupt gerechtfertigt dass
mineralwasser teilweise hundertfach
teurer ist als das wasser aus der
leitung klicks und future geht es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen
pixum gibt es jetzt übrigens auch nur
auf die ohren und zwar als podcast die
links zu apple podcast und spotify sind
unten in der video beschreibung es
herrscht eine schier endlos große
auswahl in den regalen der supermärkte
denn mineralwasser gibt es mittlerweile
wie sand am meer
eine flasche bekommt man ab etwa 30 cent
doch nach oben kennen die preise keine
grenzen so zum beispiel bei einem so
genannten luxuswasser aus kanada laut
der werbung besteht zu 100 prozent aus
aufgetautem gletschereis aus der eiszeit
und so soll es sich zitat um das
natürlich reinste abgefüllte wasser der
welt handeln und das wasser soll nicht
nur den durst löschen sondern sogar
unser gesundheit etwas gutes zu den
versprechen der hersteller zufolge
nämlich erreicht es aufgrund seiner
mikrostruktur unsere zellen besonders
schnell und trägt so zur zitat
energetisierung des körpers bei polizei
muss man dafür rund 18 euro hinlegen ein
weiteres beispiel dafür dass sich mit
wasser so richtig viel geld machen lässt
kommt aus den usa hier ist vor allem die
verpackung eine ganz besondere die
flaschen sind handgefertigt und mit
diamanten oder rubinen versieht das
wasser selbst entspringt im us
bundesstaat tennessee
und obwohl man für die besondere flasche
einige hundert euro hinlegen muss kennt
es die bevölkerung in dem kleinen us
dorf als normales trinkwasser in kreisen
der high society wird nicht nur die
verpackung sondern auch der geschmack
als besonders sexy bezeichnet besonders
rein soll das wasser sein dass auf dem
im südpazifik abgefüllt wird schließlich
gibt es dort in der näheren umgebung
keine industrie sie das wasser
verschmutzen könnte so das hauptargument
die fans von diesem angeblichen edel
wasser vergessen dabei allerdings dass
es rund 15.000 kilometer zurücklegen
muss dieses wasser dann hier bei uns in
sternerestaurants landet und das ist
alles andere als umwelt- und
klimafreundlich diese beispiele zeigen
alle sehr deutlich das wasser
mittlerweile viel mehr als seinen
eigentlichen zweck erfüllt es handelt
sich heutzutage um ein lifestyle-produkt
wasser steht für status gesundheit und
schönheit und damit lässt sich geld
verdienen die esoterik szene ist
aufgesprungen und preis bestimmtes
trinkwasser als besonders heilig oder
heilsam an verbreitet wird das vor allem
über das internet die rede ist von zitat
lebendigen oder zitat vitali siert im
wasser das den werbeversprechungen eine
deutlich höhere qualität hat als anderes
wasser aus der leitung und noch mehr
diesen vorstellungen zufolge hat dieses
wunder wasser sogar eine art gedächtnis
um informationen aus der umwelt zu
speichern
in der esoterischen welt gibt es
außerdem auch edelstein wasser das
gesundheitlichen beschwerden lindern
kann oder aber heilige quellen die
krankheiten aufgrund besonderer
schwingungen heilen können auch die
firma grander wasser aus tirol mischt
dabei mit demnach handelt es sich bei
dem wasser um ein zitat lebendiges
system das die fähigkeit hat sich zu
regenerieren der erfinder johann grander
war überzeugt davon dass sich die wasser
struktur verbessern lässt und somit
dessen selbst reinigungs und
widerstandskraft gestärkt werden kann
granda will eine quelle aufgespürt haben
dessen wasser eine zitat uhr information
enthält bis heute ist nicht klar was
diese angebliche uhr informationen
beinhalten soll
und wie sie entziffert werden kann doch
für johann grander und sein unternehmen
steht fest dass diese uhr information
auf anderes wasser übertragen werden
kann angeblich soll das andere wasser
diese informationen dann ebenfalls
aufnehmen und dadurch ebenso zitat
belebt werden seine tiroler firma will
zudem bestimmte verfahren entwickelt
haben um das wasser dahingehend zu
behandeln und somit zu verbessern die
rede ist von sogenannten
wasserbelebung geräten die die firma für
viel geld an unternehmen und
privatpersonen verkauft auf die idee
gekommen ist der unternehmer johann
grander nach eigenen angaben durch eine
eingebung gottes der chemiker helge
bergmann ist autor des buches trübe
wasser der esoterische wassermarkt und
hat zudem tiroler unternehmen und den
produkten eine ganz klare meinung kranke
hat viele gerichtsverfahren rausgekriegt
und er hat nicht einmal bewiesen oder
beweisen können oder lassen
dieses wasser informierte wasser hat
irgendeine prospektiv wissenschaft nicht
macht die wirkung es kam also zu
juristischen auseinandersetzungen
beispielsweise in neuseeland ihr wurde
der betreiber des grander wasser zu
einer schadensersatzzahlung von rund
77.000 euro verurteilt das gericht
bezeichnete seine produkte als zitat
pseudowissenschaft und quacksalberei
feststeht keine der behauptung das
grander unternehmens konnte bislang
wissenschaftlich bewiesen werden im
gegenteil viele der aufgestellten
behauptungen wurden in
wissenschaftlichen untersuchungen
widerlegt so zum beispiel von der
österreichischen bundesanstalt für
wassergüte die sich bereits vor vielen
jahren mit der folgenden behauptung
eingehend beschäftigt hatte
wasserbelebung hat eine entgiftende
wirkung dazu heißt es in der analyse der
bundesanstalt für wassergüte
granderwasser hat keinerlei entgiftende
wirkung anderslautende behauptungen wie
die zuvor von randa vertretern
getroffenen aussagen sind falsch die
angeblichen studien und
wissenschaftlichen arbeiten auf die sich
firmen wie beispielsweise das grander
unternehmen beziehen sind laut dem
chemiker helge bergmann nicht ernst zu
nehmen jahr für mich ist das ein
marktplatz von schwindlern und lügen und
denn ich habe viel korrespondiert auch
mit mit akademikern die ja dann war es
veröffentlicht haben das kochsalz
himalaya salz nur das auflöst dann
kriegt diese lösung schwingungen in die
werden von menschen nach dem trink
gewinnungen und das tut den menschen so
gut ich habe mit deswegen macht zur
universität in graz gefragt wo ist denn
diese die promo berg ich muss dir drei
mal nachfragen der wurde mir gesagt es
war ein paper
was gar nicht zur veröffentlichung
gedacht ist das steckt hinter den
angeblich wissenschaftlichen nachweisen
die immer erlogen sind das sagt jetzt
mal ganz frei und lasse mich gerne von
jemanden verklagen die mir das gegenteil
bisher hat niemand angerufen heißt also
im klartext die besonders
außergewöhnlichen und positiven
eigenschaften des wassers sind
wissenschaftliche humbug über das so
genannte gedächtnis des wassers gibt es
keine wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse
keine der genannten wirkungen des kander
wassers konnten bisher wissenschaftlich
bewiesen werden dennoch bleibt die frage
wie gesund das was er wirklich ist dass
wer täglich meist literweise zu uns
nehmen jedenfalls besser erst wenn was
literweise trinken sollten wir besser
leitungswasser aus dem hahn oder aber
mineralwasser aus dem supermarkt trinkt
letzteres wird in der werbung als
besonders rein und reich an mineralien
angepriesen
tutmann seiner gesundheit also wirklich
etwas gutes wenn man sich mineralwasser
kaufen doppel teilweise hundertfach mehr
geld ausgibt als für das wasser aus der
leitung die ergebnisse der stiftung
warentest zeigen ein klares ergebnis im
vergangenen jahr 2009 10 wurden 32
stille mineralwässer getestet und in
jedem zweiten wasser fanden die
gutachterinnen und gutachter
unerwünschte keime erhöhte gehalte an
kritischen stoffen und außerdem auch
verunreinigungen aus industrie und
landwirtschaft auch in sachen
mineralstoffen schnitten die stille
mineralwässer eher schlecht ab laut den
testergebnissen aus dem vergangenen jahr
haben einige mineralwasser sogar den
durchschnittlichen mineralstoffgehalt
der trinkwasserproben unterboten die
gesetzeslage lässt dies zu und das schon
seit 1980 demnach muss natürliches
mineralwasser keine mindest gehalt an
mineralstoffen mehr aufweisen was
hinzukommt wasser aus plastikflaschen
kann außerdem auch noch mit hormonen
belastet sein abgefülltes wasser in
flaschen ist also keineswegs die beste
option vor allem wenn man dann noch den
umweltaspekt mit einbezieht denn die
herstellung der verpackung verbraucht
energie und ressourcen genauso wie der
transport und das wiederverwerten das
umweltbundesamt bezeichnet trinkwasser
deswegen als das zitat
umweltfreundlichste getränk die
testerinnen und tester verglichen die
stille mineralwässer dann auch mit dem
leitungswasser aus dem hahn dazu
analysierten sie test wasserproben aus
öffentlichen gebäuden in 20 städten und
gemeinden
die proben wurden übrigens anordnung
genommen die ein höheres risiko
hinsichtlich der trinkwasserqualität
haben beispielsweise in den fünf größten
städten deutschlands wo über besonders
viele krankenhäuser und haushalte stoffe
ins abwasser gelangen können besonders
im visier hatten die fachleute dabei 126
stoffe wie etwa nitrate pestizide und
medikamente das ergebnis war eindeutig
zwar fanden sich in fast allen wässern
rückstände aus der umwelt doch diese
geben nach ansicht der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
keinen grund sich sorgen um die
gesundheit zu machen auch der chemiker
helge bergmann hat dazu eine ganz klare
meinung ich würde die
trinkwasserqualität alles hervorragend
beurteilen ich habe auch hier ein glas
wasser natürlich falls jetzt für mich
dort wird gerade abgezapft und ich habe
überhaupt keine bedenken wasser
verwendet für tee für suppe für zum
waschen duschen und so weiter also auch
als nahrungsmittel dass ich habe keine
bedenken
und viele dieser dinge die eine gesund
eine besseres wasser versprechen dass
wir würden rande der sagt es belebt ist
vitalisierung davon habe ich wie gesagt
keine werbewirkung zu erwarten und
deswegen ist das für mich also kein
vergleich mit dem trinkwasser
wenn das trinkwasser verbessert werden
würde dann okay das wird zum beispiel
durch co2 patrone gemacht das hat damit
der wasserqualität muss sie wieder
trennen nichts zu tun das ist diese
geschmack des wassers zwischen den
beiden dingen was er qualität was ist
drin und was er geschmack wie schmeckt
es mir sind himmelweite unterschiede die
qualität wird in deutschland übrigens
bei keinem anderen lebensmitteln so
streng kontrolliert wie beim
leitungswasser das hat auch die analyse
der stiftung warentest im vergangenen
jahr 2009 10 gezeigt insgesamt 28
städten und gemeinden deutschlands wurde
das trinkwasser getestet das ergebnis
war positiv alle besser waren so gut
dass selbst empfindliche menschen die
ihr ganzes leben lang bedenkenlos
trinken könnten falls man bedenken
bezüglich nickel cadmium oder blei hat
die vor allem
über die rohre oder armaturen in
altbauten ins trinkwasser gelangen
könnten
kann man sich das vom gesundheitsamt
oder vom wasserwerk untersuchen lassen
bestimmte labore können dann das
trinkwasser eben darauf hin analysieren
im klartext heißt das also dass wir uns
per se erst mal keine gedanken um unser
trinkwasser machen müssen trotzdem
werden wasserfilter für zu hause immer
beliebter die keime aus dem wasser
filtern sollen und zudem auch den
geschmack des wassers finden sollen laut
verbraucherschützerin und schützern ist
das aber absolut unnötig dazu schreibt
die verbraucherzentrale auf ihrer
webseite
aus hygienischer sicht ist von
wasserfiltern und wasserbehandlung
abzuraten trinkwasser ist ein
verderbliches lebensmittel das schnell
verteilt wenn es zu lange im behälter
steht oder mit alten filtern in kontakt
kommt zudem gäben wasserfilter oft auch
silber ins trinkwasser ab weil in ihnen
silbernitrat enthalten ist um eben das
verteilen zu verhindern so oder so also
nichts wirklich tolles sprich egal ob
esoterisch aufgearbeitetes wasser
irgendwelches exotisches wasser warum in
die ferne schweifen wenn das gute liegt
so nah neben trinkwasser aus der leitung
und egal ob berliner perle oder bad
kranenburger was aus dem wasserhahn
kommt ist kontrolliert gut und meine
empfehlung also genauso übrigens wie
dieses video dieses mundschutz wegen co2
ungesund anklicken anschauen und einfach
medizin abonnieren super kanal bis dann
bleibt dran